hey Leute was geht ab und herzlich
willkommen zum neuen Video ich hoffe
natürlich euch geht es allen gut ihr
seht schon ich sehe glaube ich deutlich
entspannter aus als gestern ich habe
mich erstmal gut ausgepennt das coole
ist ich bin nicht mehr alleine was geht
alles gut ja ja auf jeden Fall ein sehr
guter Freund von mir ist netterweise
dazu gestoßen ist jetzt gerade vom
Flughafen gekommen und wir werden ab
jetzt die Reise auf jeden Fall gemeinsam
weiter antreten das ist echt entspannt
weil alleine reisen so lange ist
wirklich nervig auf jeden Fall ist das
Wetter heute nicht so geil in Budapest
ich habe gestern natürlich schon
bisschen gesehen habe jetzt nicht
wirklich viel mitgefilmt wir gehen jetzt
erstmal was essen und dann haben wir
heute abend nach Bukarest mit dem Zug
also ich habe schon gebucht für zwei
Personen mit schlafabteilung und so ich
bin mal gespannt was das wird nähere
Infos dazu später erstmal entspannt was
Essen hier ist alles wirklich deutlich
günstiger als in Deutschland das ist
sehr nice und ich zeige euch jetzt ein
paar kleine Eindrücke von Budapest und
dann freue ich mich später auf den Zug
let's go irgendwie reden hier auch super
viele Menschen Leute ich glaube das hat
man gerade gehört bei der dahinten die
Touris sind da
manjana ABC sieht eigentlich aus wie so
ein Erotikladen aber ist ein Supermarkt
mit versteckter Stripshow oh diesmal
darf meine Kameralinse nicht wieder
dreckig werden es tut mir leid es kann
halt mal passieren wenn man so viel
unterwegs ist das da ein bisschen Dreck
drauf ist
so leute wir gehen jetzt zu good Burger
Burger essen Kranke Bewertung
[Musik]
so Leute wir haben auf jeden Fall gerade
ein super super leckeren Burger gegessen
das krasse ist wir haben bezahlt für
zwei Burger Pommes zwei Getränke 21 €,
da kann man glaube ich wirklich nicht
meckern jetzt geht's noch ein leckeres
Bierchen trinken und dann müssen wir
auch schon zeitnah zum Zug also gut wir
haben noch so drei vier Stunden aber
vielleicht schafft man auch zwei wir
hier ist so ein Markt ach so das sieht
cool aus
thank you so Bier endlich gefunden
cheers wir haben hier auf jeden Fall ein
Local Bier
schmeckt wie Wasser oder so wie Kölsch
bisschen egal so Leute wir sind hier auf
jeden Fall gerade in einem ungarischen
Pub das ist extrem nice das ist ja alles
so aufgebaut wie so eine alte Ruine
deswegen heißt es auch old Ruine Pubs
also die sind hier so alle nebeneinander
und man kommt hier rein cooler Eingang
du kannst ja auch einmal hochfilmen da
oben kann man dann auch so keine Ahnung
was man da genau machen kann aber es
sieht auf jeden Fall sehr sehr wild aus
und ja wir trinken hier ein bisschen was
und dann geht's gleich hinzu und ich
habe gehört abends wird das ganze dann
hier zu einer also echt schade dass wir
heute Abend schon wieder weg sind aber
na ja also wenn ihr meinen Bruder besser
seid abchecken
so Leute wir sind mittlerweile raus aus
der Bar und hinter mir warte mal hier
schaut mal da kann man sehen dass der
Bahnhof wir waren ja auch gestern schon
und jetzt gleich geht's weiter ich freue
mich schon sehr Nachtzug nach Bukarest
das wird auch die längste Reise dieses
Trips soweit ich weiß wir sind 14 oder
15 Stunden unterwegs aber wir haben zum
Glück unseren eigenen Abteil deswegen
hoffe ich dass das Ganze entspannt wird
wir werden uns jetzt gleich noch
irgendwas zu Essen holen weil ich weiß
nicht wie die Restaurant Möglichkeiten
an Bord sind schauen wir dann mal man
muss ja vorher gut Aussagen und ja ich
muss sagen der Bahnhof von Budapest
schaut euch das mal an gerade jetzt hier
so bei dem Diesel Wetter und so sieht
das schon sehr sehr nice aus paar Turi
Bilder noch und freut sich schon auf
deine erste nachtzugfahrt ja auf jeden
Fall super geil
ja das hat man so ein und Youtube
gehyped ist immer gut und Leute deswegen
auf jeden Fall alle fleißig den Channel
abonnieren für die nächsten Party es
kommt noch einiges und mal schauen ob
wir wirklich in Istanbul ankommen aber
der Plan wird schon irgendwie klappen
nur was ich auch noch dazu sagen muss
und zwar kann man also das Ticket von
Bukarest nach Istan cool das ist das
einzige Ticket der Reise was man online
nicht buchen kann das kann ich erst
buchen wenn ich in Bukarest bin am
Bahnhof ich hoffe dass es klappt we will
see Alter ey da kannst du ja wirklich
sehr filmreif vielleicht liegt es auch
nur daran weil ich schon zwei Bier
getrunken habe Leute wir sehen uns
okay wir müssen dazu gleich sechs was da
hinten ist glaube ich schon dazu gehört
also man muss sagen am Bahnhof hier ein
Budapest gibt's auf jeden Fall einige
kleine Läden aber kein Supermarkt also
das ist echt irgendwie ein bisschen
komisch wir waren auf jeden Fall gerade
noch bei einem Supermarkt hier um die
Ecke weil wir halt nicht wissen ob man
an Bord irgendwas zu essen bekommen ich
verstehe auf den Tickets gar nichts also
ich weiß dass wir halten Privatanteil
gebucht haben aber sonst ob es ein
Restaurant gibt oder ob wir essen dabei
haben keine Ahnung es war halt alles auf
Ungarisch die Buchung aber ich glaube
wirklich dass das hier ja das müsste
unser Zug sein ja doch eine Nummern das
passt
ja okay du hast doch die Tickets oder
wir haben den ersten Wagen ich hoffe es
ist ein vernünftiger Schlafwagen ey es
tut mir sonst auch leid aber wir müssen
diesen Zug halt nehmen
egal ich bin es mittlerweile schon
gewohnt aber es ist halt von Louis die
erste nachtzugfahrt ja ja das sieht gut
aus nee eigentlich hatte ich sogar
schlafbetten komm sleeping Chao okay
super das ist scheint so als wäre das
wirklich besser als die letzten dich
getestet habe so hier oben steht
sleeping car 422 das ist unser
vernünftige Betten diesmal ja man
endlich keine Liegewagen mehr wo ich
nicht schlafen kann und mein Rücken
bricht
können wir jetzt mal einschalten hier
endlich mal was vernünftiges hier ja das
ist unser
Zigarette oder
haben die Plätze 56 und 52 passt doch
oder ja so Leute wir sind in unserem
Abteil angekommen was meinst du geht
oder ja ist gut ist okay die
Jugendherberge früher aber Klassenfahrt
es ist auf jeden Fall wirklich das Beste
Abteil was ich je hatte auf all meinen
Nachtzug warten ich gebe euch gleich
eine schnelle roomtour aber wird chillen
jetzt erstmal ein bisschen in der eh
hier noch ziemlich lange drin ja schauen
wir mal was wird fahren verlassen
Budapest um Punkt 19:10 Uhr erstmal hier
das hat sogar ein Ungarn pünktlich
klappt ne leider sieht man nicht mehr so
viel es ist ja schon dunkel wir haben
hier oben mal das Fenster aufgemacht
super nice das konnte ich sonst nie in
der Nacht liegen wir fahren jetzt
erstmal entspannt hier raus dann zeige
ich euch noch ein bisschen was lass mal
die Farbe auf uns zukommen wir sind
wirklich echt lange hier drin aber ich
bin glücklich dass es hier so
komfortabel ist wie ich noch nie gesehen
habe echt top
[Musik]
also was zu essen kann man hier nicht
kaufen aber der schaffen kann wird
unseren Kaffee machen egal was ist das
überhaupt der hat sich das einfach alles
notiert also ich hätte das Ticket auch
so faken können die Scan das hier nicht
ein die schreiben das einfach ab dann
irgendwelche komischen Codes vom Ticket
und dann der hat sogar den Preis vom
Ticket abgeschrieben hä okay Leute ich
würde euch jetzt einfach mal schnell
eine roomtour geben hier von unserem
kleinen Abteil also eigentlich ist es
wie ein Mini kleines Hotelzimmer ganz
entspannt und ja schauen wir mal das
hier ist die Tür hier steht auch unsere
Nummer wir haben hier die 56 guck mal
hast du schon gesehen hat hier irgendwas
drauf geschrieben wir gehen gleich auf
jeden Fall auch noch mal raus hier haben
wir unsere Sachen geparkt alkoholfrei
und kann man seinen Jacke aufhängen dann
haben wir hier einmal unten schlafe ich
es ist ein bisschen breiter würde ich
sagen als die letzten Nachtzüge trotzdem
natürlich nicht so viel Platz aber das
Bett ist deutlich bequemer und oben
schläft Luis ich hoffe du kannst ganz
gut schlafen hier das gute war das Bett
war schon bezogen hier haben wir auch
Wasser paar hygienesachen ist das eine
achso Zahnbürste sogar cool ja nice wir
können halt hier unsere Zähne putzen wir
dachten eigentlich das ist eine Toilette
aber ich glaube es ist ein Waschbecken
Fenster ist auf das Wasser eigentlich
schon mehr kann man jetzt hier nicht
wirklich berichten ach so hier oben
haben wir noch eine Klimaanlage hier
kann man die Temperaturen einstellen und
das war's wir haben jetzt heute halt
Mittwoch ich bin ja am Montag
losgefahren das heißt ich bin jetzt
schon deutlich länger als 48 Stunden
unterwegs wir befinden uns gerade hier
noch in Budapest und fahren dann jetzt
bis nach Bukarest das sind Luftlinie ca
700 km wir werden auf jeden Fall mehr
als 14 Stunden unterwegs sein aber so
ist das normal und was ich jetzt noch
geändert hat an der ganzen Sache ich
muss auch sagen ich bin gestern halt
extrem Budapest geblieben weil Luis halt
dazu kam und ich habe ihn auf ihn
gewartet damit ich nicht alleine
weiterfahren muss wir haben jetzt aber
auch noch folgendes geplant wir sind ja
morgen in Bukarest da werden wir auch
eine Nacht bleiben einfach um uns die
Stadt anzuschauen weil es wäre schade
einfach weiterzufahren und das gleiche
werden wir dann natürlich auch machen
wenn wir in Istanbul sind da freue ich
mich schon sehr drauf wir waren dabei
noch nicht deswegen wird sicherlich
ziemlich nice genau jetzt gleich ist
ungefähr 20 Uhr keine Ahnung wenn wir
schlafen gehen wir haben mehr als genug
Zeit melde mich bis später so Leute was
geht wir haben jetzt mittlerweile kurz
vor 10 Uhr sind jetzt seit ja gut 3
Stunden Zug irgendwie ist uns
aufgefallen der fährt so lahm Alter also
wirklich guck mal wir fahren die ganze
Zeit so also kein Wunder dass man 14
Stunden oder so für Budapest nach
Bukarest braucht kann man nichts machen
ich habe zwar nur eine Boxershorts an
aber wir gehen jetzt mal raus das ist
nämlich normal das darf man also warum
im letzten noch wie du dann hier kann
man
eine Dusche
Alter wie unfair der hat einen Dusche
und die Betten sind bequem immer noch
da hinten ist ein Abteil der hat mir
einfach eine Dusche und so ein Toiletten
das ist gleicher Wagen aber das ist leer
das ist ja noch Frechheit naja egal also
da ist auf jeden Fall keiner da können
wir uns auch hinlegen wo sind wir denn
gerade was steht hier irgendwas wir sind
auf jeden Fall wir halten an fast jedem
Bahnhof ne keine Ahnung ob ich mich noch
mal melde vielleicht gehen wir einfach
schlafen und dann sehen wir morgen noch
einiges von Rumänien wenn wir auch
stehen weil es wird ja relativ ja und
jetzt hell 7 Uhr oder so wir sehen uns
wir wurden gerade hier an der Kante
kontrolliert Police Police Police was
hast du denn da
was hat er gesucht Leute schreibt mal in
die Kommentare was hat der Bregen hat
gesucht von der Polizei
da hinten guck mal was fertig
so da draußen wo fährt was da fährt was
dahinten wie so ein nikolaus-express
oder so siehst das ja witzig was ist das
naja Leute wir schlafen jetzt gute Nacht
dein Handy ist runtergefallen hast du
denn gut durchgeschlafen
ja
[Musik]
sind
ja aus wie bei uns in Bielefeld oh ja
ganz guten Sträucher haben wir da auch
die Sträucher kennbar ey welches Hotel
soll ich buchen
irgendeins Gas Sonera kuschelta 16 €
frühstück ist inklusive ist das geil
krass das ist kein krass so Leute die
Nacht war auf jeden Fall ganz in Ordnung
ich würde sagen für mich die beste
Nachtzug Nacht bis jetzt und wir fahren
jetzt noch ungefähr zwei Stunden dann
sind wir im Bukarest und ja ich freue
mich schauen wir mal was wird was wird
Stunden Kaffee aber hast du denn
schaffen heute morgen schon gesehen
schon aber dabei hat er geschlafen
erschaffner
[Musik]
der hat die ganze Nacht Doodle Jump
gespielt erschaffen
so Leute hier kann man jetzt auf jeden
Fall die ersten rumänischen
Schrebergärten sehen hallo und hier auch
jetzt Häuser genau ja so sieht das hier
aus einer Luis guck mal moinsen krass ne
ich bin mal gespannt so Leute mit einer
Verspätung von einer halben Stunde ca
sind wir fast da also wir sind jetzt
sofort da auf jeden Fall ganz nett hier
auf geht's
[Musik]
Alter das sieht schon crazy aus wie der
Bahnhof ne wieder aber irgendwie hat das
was aussteigen
endlich da war wie lange waren wir jetzt
unterwegs 15 Stunden es war echt lange
aber wir haben es geschafft und sind in
Bukarest nice
[Musik]
der Plan ist auf jeden Fall jetzt wir
verlassen erstmal den Bahnhof schauen
wir wo sind also ungefähr weiß ich ja
aber ich habe halt jetzt ein Hotel
gebucht da müssen wir jetzt hin dann
erkunden wir natürlich mal ein bisschen
Bukarest weil wir bleiben hier bis
morgen das ganz nice normalerweise habe
ich ja schon gesagt würde ich einfach
weiterfahren aber das macht ja keinen
Sinn wenn wir jetzt schon mal hier zu
zweit sind dann muss man das ja auch
immer ein bisschen angucken ich kann ja
gar nichts nee du auch nicht
[Musik]
so sieht übrigens der Bahnhof von
Bukarest aus da muss man ja wirklich
sagen hatte Budapest ein deutlich
schöneren Bahnhof ne aber ja werden wir
noch gar nicht sehen
[Musik]
werdet
Weg
conneburg okay
[Musik]
Alter hier sieht das aber auch aus
überall wo sind wir denn hier gelandet
also im Vergleich zu dem
unfreundlichsten Deutsche Bahn
Fahrkartenkontrolleur war die Frau
gerade am Schalter deutlich
unfreundlicher also das habe ich noch
nie erlebt sowas die hat uns plötzlich
einfach ignoriert ich dachte hey kommt
da jetzt noch was no Go ja genau Leute
schaut mal hier Alter
crazy und was hast du gerade gesagt
hässlichste Stadt Europas bis jetzt ne
echt krass also das ist schon eine ganz
andere Welt hier meine ist natürlich
alles nicht abwerten aber vielleicht
können wir auch noch schöne Recken so
Leute was geht wir haben es gepackt sind
im Hotel können uns erstmal ein bisschen
ausruhen haben beide geduscht hier für
das Nachtleben in Bukarest mal schauen
was hier so heute abgeht ich bin
gespannt ich muss auch ganz ehrlich
sagen ich bin noch nie auf die Idee
gekommen nach Bukarest zu fahren
deswegen es ist schon echt crazy hier
das ist auf jeden Fall die Aussicht aus
unserem Zimmer wir haben natürlich mit
City View gebucht wie fandest du deine
erste Nacht okay
hier können wir heute auf jeden Fall
besser schlafen und kuscheln ja genau so
etwas geht wir sind jetzt mittlerweile
hier schon in Istanbul angekommen im
Hotel ist auf jeden Fall noch einiges
passiert aber das werdet ihr noch
erfahren und ich muss noch die Bewertung
machen vom Nachtzug von Budapest nach
Bukarest und das machen wir jetzt du
kannst mal von 1 bis 5 Sterne geben das
schlechteste wir starten mit Komfort wie
komfortabel
ich muss sagen es war auf jeden Fall der
komfortabelste Nachtzug für Nachtzug in
Ordnung von mir gibt's da vier von fünf
Sterne bist du nicht was gefehlt hat
also eigentlich hatten wir alles aber
dein Rücken tut weh das natürlich auch
hier okay vier Sterne nächster Punkt
Essen gab's nichts kann man auch nichts
geben ja null es ist Frechheit
eigentlich finde ich auch das ist schon
irgendwie was zu essen geben sollte vor
allem wenn man dann halt das teuerste
Bucht Service gab es halt auch nicht
außer ein guter schafft aber nett ne
aber sonst hatte man keinen Service
würde ich mal sagen zwei von fünf
naturerlebnisfaktor ich hätte mir
irgendwie mehr erhofft also es war schon
cool so durch Rumänien zu fahren man
sieht halt oftmals zu diesen Unterschied
so abgebrannte Häuser und dann aber auch
voll moderne Fabriken das ist alles so
nebeneinander und auch moderne Gebäude
also Rumänien ist alles andere als
ranzig heißt ja manchmal so ein Vorteil
gut es gibt natürlich auch schon Stellen
wo wir uns gefragt haben ja habt ihr
wahrscheinlich auch gesehen
naturerlebnisfaktor würde ich auch
eigentlich nur zwei von fünf Sterne
geben
nach draußen
aber wenn ich was gesehen habe dann war
es eigentlich auch so schön wie du es
gesagt hast und dann zum Schluss noch
Preis-Leistung wird sagen für Nachtzug
eigenes Abteil 105 € pro Person kann man
nicht meckern müsste man eigentlich 55
Sterne geben okay super man muss nur
leider sagen eine schlechte Nachricht
gibt es und zwar ihr werdet natürlich
alles im nächsten Part dann erfahren und
ich bin mal gespannt wie lange es noch
dauern wird bis wir in Istanbul ankommen
aber es gab wohl ziemlich lange den
Bosporus Express das waren Entzug der
zwischen bukares Istanbul und Sofia der
bulgarischen Hauptstadt verkehrt ist wir
uns eben die nette Dame am Schalter
mitgeteilt hat gibt es keine direkte
Verbindung mehr man kann versuchen
irgendwie nach Bulgarien zu kommen und
von da aus da nach Istanbul das sollte
wohl gehen aber wie lange das dauert
wusste die nicht und ja ich stehe halt
bis jetzt noch ohne Ticket da oder für
uns beide und wir schauen mal wie wir
das machen ich hoffe dass es klappt weil
es wäre unfassbar scheiße wenn es daran
jetzt Zeit hat ja dass da halt keine
Zugverbindung mehr gibt na ja wenn noch
was passiert heute abend blende ich euch
jetzt noch ein hier gerade wir werden
wahrscheinlich keine Ahnung was machen
wir hier Rumänien Budapest bukare okay
da geht ja schon oder man partylife ist
ja hier schon da Leute abonniert super
gerne den Kanal für die letzte Folge
wenn ihr die nicht verpassen wollt es
wird wirklich Abenteuer Reich ich bin
super gespannt und ich freue mich sehr
auf Istanbul da war ich auch noch nie
danke fürs zuschauen dann noch oben wäre
nice und glaubst du wir kommen heile
allein in Istanbul morgen oder
übermorgen auf jeden Fall ja das ist ja
schon mal gut
oder über übermorgen wer weiß Leute haut
rein ciao